Hello again! Welcome to another episode of
community questions that I'm allowed to host!
I've decided to move the
format around a little bi:
All these questions are in some way
about regularization techniques.
So instead of going through them rather randomly
I'll try to explain things a bit more orderily.
Feel free to skip to either
part using the timestamps below.
So, what is regularization?
Yes everyone who writes it with a "z"
is a bloody savage, sorry Letitia!
A regularization is any technique
that helps your neural network to
solve your objective function in a better way.
Put simplym your objective or loss
function tells your net what to do
and regularization is added to
tell it how it should do that.
As a simple example consider fitting
a function through these given points.
While the red curve does hit every
sample point it generalizes badly
for the samples not seen during
training – it is overfitting.
A regularization term here
could enforce smoothness giving you
that nice green curve that you can see.
Usually, these regularizations are added
as an extra term to the loss function.
So, two very common regularizations that are
already built in in most optimizers such as Adam,
would be l1 and Tikhonov regularization,
that is also known as l2 or weight decay.
L1 regularization just adds the absolute sum
of all weights of the network to the loss term,
whereas Tikhonov or l2 regularization
does the same for the squared weights.
In practice that just means that L1 does
not care which weights we actually touch,
as long as we are always getting lower in total.
For l2 regularization this changes
as we square each weight this is always
punishing the highest weight the most.
So, while l2 regularization and Tikhonov mean the
same, l2 regularization shrinks the weights more
evenly than l1 preferring to punish the higher
weights more than the lower ones . And l2 does
this in a linear way always just preferring
to get the total sum of the weights down.
If we reconsider our example from the beginning,
we can easily see why having either regularization
term is helpful: To form a curve such as the
red line we'd need much higher weights. Very
informally spoken – please don't hit me for that
– sharper turns of the output function require
larger weights, whereas for example a flat line
can be produced just with all weights being zero.
So, this also helps against
overfitting while improving
generalization. By preferring
the green over the red line,
easy solutions just tend to generalize better than
memorizing every last bit of the training data.
Now let's look at one regularization
for the analysis (calculus) lovers.
Let's quickly repeat what Lipschitz
continuity is and see how we can use that to,
for example better train GANs or
defend against adversarial attacks.
A function is Lipschitz continuous with the
Lipschitz constant c, if a change applied
to its input value never changes the output
value by more than c times that input change.
Or, with other words there is some upper
limit to the slope of this function.
As our networks are also just
piecewise linear functions,
we can also compute the
Lipschitz constant for them.
Discretely spoken, this means that for
any two samples of the input their output
distance relative to the input distance
should at most be that Lipschitz constant.
Meaning, for a network that
is Lipschitz continuous when
we fiddle around with one single input,
the output change occurring has some upper bound.
And that is already the answer to this question.
A simple way of enforcing Lipschitz
continuity is the so-called weight clipping.
The output of a network always depends on its
weights and when we simply set an upper limit to
the absolute value of a weight, that is we just
clip any weight that is larger than this limit,
we already obtain a very crude limit on how much
the change in the input can change the output,
leaving us with a Lipschitz bound.
it's just the same argument as before
for the l1 and l2 regularization.
High slope needs higher values as coefficient,
meaning high weights in the network.
And by enforcing that our weights
are small, we make sure that the
learned function does not have any of
these sharp turns that we do not want.
Now, let's have a look at what else this is
good for: imagine that you want to train a GAN,
and I'm explicitly saying "imagine" here,
because these things are a pain to train.
So you train your GAN,
and during training your discriminator
becomes way too good for the generator.
That means that you suddenly have a strong
jump in your discriminator and meaning that
when your generator is producing super fake
outputs slightly changing something as you'd
usually do when training networks, won't help at
all: your output will still be very much fake.
Hence you basically end up with
a vanishing gradient problem;
there is just no clear direction in which
your gradient points that can help you.
You'd need to change a whole lot
of things and then suddenly the
discriminator gets to this jump and
thinks your generated output is real.
And this of course means that you can't
properly train your generator anymore.
Big problem lots of headache,
so what do you do about that?
Well you don't want these jumps in
your loss function. You want your
loss function to smoothly change
with a limited rate of change,
which is exactly what a Lipschitz
bound for your network does.
So, for example you enforce Lipschitz
continuity through weight clipping
and boom! things get better. Mostly.
Sometimes. GANs are lots of fun!
Now, before you run off and use that knowledge,
don't! Because there is an even
better regularization technique.
Lipschitz continuity prevents you
from having steep changes in the loss,
but it does not prevent local optima or the
function changing only slowly or not at all.
Much better than that, we can simply say that
our network should not be Lipschitz bound,
but instead also exactly change by some
constant relative to the input change,
meaning our regularization term is
just enforcing a constant gradient
for example one everywhere, which in theory
means that there is no local optimum anymore!
A function, a neural network, with a
constant gradient like one everywhere
has not one spot where the gradient is zero! It
is just some linear function and as we all know a
local optimum has always a gradient of zero and on
such a linear function we can train even better.
Lastly, Lipschitz regularization can
also help us against adversarial attacks.
For adversarial attacks we usually
look for a tiny shift in the input
that causes a large shift in the output.
For example, when we add almost invisible
noise perturbations to this image of a panda,
we can make it look like a given to
a classifier that we trained before.
Well, if only there was such a thing
to make sure these tiny input changes
do not totally change the output!
Well, again Lipschitz regularization to the
rescue! Enforcing a somewhat low Lipschitz
constant for the network, means that for
an input that is only slightly changed,
we cannot change the output by much. Or in
other words, we need to shift a lot more pixels
much more visibly to change this panda into
a gibbon in the eyes of our classifier.
So, I hope that this was somewhat
useful to you. As always,
I would be very happy for some feedback
in the comments and we'll leave you some
additional links and sources
in the comments (description).
Bye bye!